you know we alternate the chairmanship
of Xiao car each year from the Senate to
the house last year Senator Reagan was
our chair so this year we would look for
a House member and I would I would
nominate representative McGuire to that
position who served as Vice chair last
year
it's been moved and seconded to nominate
representative McGuire as the chair this
is when you don't show up you get
elected to things
um
so are there any other nominations for
chair
not seeing any Out close nominations uh
all those in favor of Rosa McGuire's
nominated his chair say aye
aye opposed nay eyes have it Carol
you've been nominated this chair
congratulations all right so we'll move
into the uh business
um the first order of business will be
the consent calendar are there any items
wishing to be removed from the consent
calendar
one second not that I know of uh we will
need to approve the minutes also oh
thank you very much
so seeing uh see uh seeing no items
being removed I'd entertain a motion to
approve the consent agenda
it's been moved by sin of the ward
seconded by uh representative Schmidt
any discussion on the consent agenda
seeing none all those in favor say aye
aye opposed nay
the consent agenda has been adopted
I'm trying to find the minutes uh the
minutes next up are the minutes
um I remember what date that was we had
our last meeting November 17th moved to
approve it's been moved by
representative to approve the
Schmidt to approve the minutes of
November 17th is there a second
it's been seconded by Senator Ward any
discussions on the minutes as written
and presented
seeing none all those in favor say aye
aye all those opposed Nang the eyes have
one-up State one abstention
sure two abstentions uh minutes are
approved
Mike next order businesses
first item on the regular calendar I
believe
so next stop is the officer professional
licensure
um 22-8 on recreational therapists
uh some Mr Vice chair uh this is an
interim Rule and it had quite a number
of comments so uh
would you prefer that I go through each
one individually and then pass it over
to the agency or we do one comment have
the agency respond and go why don't you
go through your list and then the agency
can respond to your list sure absolutely
so the first comment appears on page two
of the rule page eight of the packet
there's a website link on there that
doesn't work and it doesn't spell out
the URL so that wasn't unclear comment
as this is a interim Rule and that needs
to be easily accessible by the public
there is a note to jail car on page
three of the rule page nine of the
packet just talking about uh the bill
that
resulted in this interim rule
House Bill
1446 dissolved the recreational therapy
governing board which was effective on
July 19 2022 and made an Advisory Board
under the oplc which ties into the note
to jail car on the last page just
informing the committee that at this
time the recreational governing board
had existing rules when this statute
went into effect and those rules are
still effective at this time as was
discussed at the last meeting for
interim rule seven there is now a
question of who has the authority to
repeal those rules
which is an ongoing problem as there are
two other
boards that were under the spill that
had the same thing occur
moving on to the next substantive
comment there was an edit unclear
comment on page three of the rules
um it mentions the retention schedule
established pursuant to the statute but
the statute does not lay out the
retention schedule it gives the oplc the
authority to create that schedule and
there's no site to the retention
schedule in that particular Rule and it
does not lay out the schedule in that
rule there's a legislative intent
comment on page 10. saying the executive
director May Grant initial licenses but
it doesn't State what the criteria are
for which licenses will be granted or
how the licenses will be
um
viewed to see which ones will be
granted which could result in oral rule
making and violation of RSA 541a221
there's another unclear comment on page
10 once again having to do with
um
I'm sorry uh having to do with the
board's website and the fee amount
that's listed in the rule the amount
listed in the rule is different than
what's in the board's website
um
a screenshot of the board's website is
attached in the final in the interim
rule packet
and the same comment appears on uh page
19 as there's another rule another fee
amount cited that's different from
what's on the board's website
there's an edit unclear comment on page
five where the form submitted to OLS
only lists a space for the length of
experience
when it states that the licensee must
have
the same uh crite or has met the same
criteria as was previously needed so
it's unclear what criteria is being
considered as the form only has that one
space for the length of experience
unclear on page 12.
and the rule says when the application
becomes available online
but the oplc website says that paper
applications are no longer accepted so
there is a discrepancy on there as well
and once again there is a screenshot of
the oplc's website in the packet
there's an unclear comment on page 10
that says to pay the fee in PLC
1001 for recreational therapists but as
of now that particular rule does not
exist there's no mention of fees for
recreational therapists in the PLC 1000s
and there's also no mention of the fee
on the website
there's an unclear uh comment on page
13. where the rule uses the language
that the licensees
will be notified when
the website is under contract to notify
so that the licenses might start using
the website as opposed to submitting
things directly to the oplc
that language is unclear because
saying under contract doesn't mean that
the site is operational and there could
be a amount of time between when
something becomes under contract to when
it is actually operational
there's another unclear comment on page
13. uh the rule as worded said
until an online system becomes available
[Music]
the oplc will use this particular
auditing process but it does not specify
what the auditing process will be after
the system becomes online
on page 19 as well there's another
unclear comment
which states
um for which disciplinary action can be
taken once again it does not establish
criteria of when the disciplinary action
will be taken and also does not cite the
rules that disa that deal with
disciplinary action so what disciplinary
action
could potentially be taken and so once
again that leaves room for oral rule
making which could be in violation of
RSA 541a 22 1. thank you
got all that Courtney
I did
thank you
um Senator Ling Mr Vice chair and um
members of the committee for the record
my name is Lindsey Corney I'm the
executive director of oplc so just
before I address specific comments this
board was converted to an Advisory Board
last session because we had Quorum
issues that I believe that the prior
governing board had not met for about a
year and a half and so there were issues
with the ability to obviously regulate
but also to license applicants so what
we did in terms of moving forward with
interim rules is we largely took what
was existing so that we could get them
in the PLC rules and we are now
proceeding with drafting the regular
rulemaking process which will include an
advanced public comment period in early
January so to the extent that there are
substantive changes that need to happen
as well as comments that we should
respond to that OLS has provided we
would suggest that that would be the
best time to do it
um in terms of specific comments
um the uh
I guess I'll start with the retention
schedule issue their retention schedules
are filed generally with the state
archives that has been approved we're
happy to post that on our website but
that
um is typically done outside of the
rulemaking process and we did just get
approval from the Secretary of State's
office regarding our retention schedule
in terms of the fee issues there are
different fees currently located on our
website because the fees have yet to be
changed so if we if we do get approval
um if these rules are approved we will
have an effective date that post dates
this meeting and we'll make sure that
the website lines up appropriately with
whatever the fees are
in terms of the
see
temporary license fee issue the PLC
1001.07 was actually on consent today so
I I do believe that that issue has been
resolved and that the committee has
approved a change of a fee from 100 to
25 and again we'll adjust that on the
website as needed in terms of discipline
we would suggest that our PLC 200s are
the appropriate regulatory Authority for
disciplinary issues we're not ever going
to be able to fully capture every
instance in which disciplinary action is
warranted but I think that the
procedures are well laid out in PLC 200s
and we can certainly respond more
clearly with regular rulemaking to OLS
comments
um and then I think I had a couple of
others I apologize
um some of the website link stuff we can
um
we can either make that change it the
links work for us when we tried it so I
apologize that there that they didn't
work our intent was not to incorporate a
website by reference
um so we can certainly when we proceed
to regular rulemaking make sure that the
link is is is working as necessary
um and then in terms of on page four
there was a question about
licensees who essentially were blanketed
and grandfathered in whatever phrase you
want to use it at the time that
recreational therapy licensure was
required it basically stated that the
board can issue May issue licenses to
individuals who had already been
practicing with certain credentials if
they had received a credential prior to
I think it was 2007. practically I don't
think this is an issue anymore because
licensure is now required so they would
have to go through the regular process
and we would suggest that we probably
eliminate this as we proceed with rather
regular rulemaking but we elected to
keep it in to avoid making any
substantive changes until the regular
rulemaking process and we can receive
more comments from the public
I think those were the are the comments
that I would generally offer but I'm
happy to answer any questions the
committee may have
thank you
so Mike I'm going to ask you if you
don't mind put you on the spot there are
a lot of new members and so understand
the difference between you know a
conditional rule an interim rule final
Rule and understanding what that means
to the members and what we're approving
could you kind of run through that for
the members I will this is an interim
rule it if adopted it would only be in
effect for 180 days
in the meantime the agency would go
through regular rulemaking to replace
the interim rule that's often been the
committee's practice in the case of an
interim rule that they do as suggested
by director Courtney I mean
and uh
that uh
there be a recommendation or uh
understanding by the committee when they
approve the rule that the issues that
are in there by raised by committee
staff would be addressed during a
regular roommate however if the
committee feels that some of these
issues are so important that they need
to be addressed immediately a committee
can preliminarily object
thank you so uh uh Miss Courtney the the
um edits that they have made you're
acceptable the edits and comments that
the uh and we could adopt the rule with
the edits inclusive that we talked about
yes okay
any further questions from committee
members for director Courtney
hearing none Mr chairman I will move to
approve with the recommendation that was
referenced
it's been moved to approve the interim
rules with the edits suggested by staff
is there a second
it's been second by Senate award any
further discussion
seeing none all those in favor say aye
aye opposed name
eyes have it and the interim rule is
adopted as edited
next up is the board of natural
scientists uh rule 2277.
so this is a conditional approval which
means they they did a final approval
sorry they did a final proposal and I
reviewed it and they came back with with
more edits so you'll be voting on The
conditional approval text
um there's actually only one issue with
this Rule and that is that on page two
of the conditional approval
um there's one section of rules that has
been expired since 2019
um their those rules are about the
explanation of a rule after it's been
adopted
um and so I
the gel car may have questions about how
they were doing that during the
expiration period thank you just one
second so generally the idea is agencies
aren't allowed to enforce rules once
rules have expired so the standard
question is how have you been forcing
the rule or have there been any
enforcement actions on the rule after it
expired
I'm Tina Kelly
on the program specialists at the office
of professional licensure and
certification and with regard to this
particular rule there would be two other
um
guidance that would be accepted because
it's an explanation after adoption of a
rule it would be both 91a and for any
procedural Justice 800s we would rely on
and I am not sure I haven't seen
anything where this was even an issue
any further questions from the committee
and staff we're we're good with there's
there's no further edits needed on this
no the the rule other than that is fine
great
um except to be looking for a motion to
approve the conditional so moved it's
been moved for uh to approve the
conditional rule is there a second
second it's been second by
representative Lynn any further
discussion
seeing none uh all those in favor say
aye aye opposed nay eyes have it then
your rules adopted thank you
next up is the Department of Safety
vehicle registration rules
2284. Steph
yes thank you Mr Vice chair
so
the only substantive comments on this
particular rule had to do with the forms
just so the committee is aware forms are
considered rules under the statute and
therefore have to go through the rule
making process
so the issue with the forms that were
Incorporated by reference in this rule
is that some of them had revision dates
that did not correspond with rulemaking
so olfs did ask for the Department for
an explanation and after submitting the
final packet did receive some additional
information for the department so with
regard to the comment on page seven of
the rule
it was explained that this is actually a
new form that is being adopted with
these particular rules so that
substantive comment would actually be
converted to an editorial comment that
the date just needs to correspond for
when the rules are approved by this
committee and adopted
with regard to
the uh substantive comments on page 13
and 17 those two
I'm sorry page 17 and
um page 67 of the packet which would be
uh page 61 of the rules those two forms
was explained that they had very minor
editorial changes which are allowed
outside of the rulemaking process
um as they weren't substantive and did
not affect anything to do with the
information being provided so those
comments have been removed in the final
form on page 13 of the rules that one
does remain a substantive comment as the
information provided shows that this
particular form was substantially
revised outside of the rulemaking
process
and therefore if the committee has any
questions for the Department we wanted
to leave that on the regular agenda for
you to address
good morning
can you hear me
my name's martiniani from the Department
of Safety
um the issue with the vanity plate the
we went through rule making back in 2019
and adopted
um rules to reflect that there are new
you could get vanity plates for
um decals and motorcycle so it's number
16 17 and 18. so the form was changed to
reflect that you could check those boxes
off as well and that has an effective
date of January of 20 which was a month
after the rules were adopted the form
was not Incorporated by reference in the
rules so I I that's the only substantive
comment uh substantive change to that
rule and then of course editorially the
change in director
uh so that is correct the particular
section that incorporates that form by
reference was not included in those
November rules which is why the form was
technically amended outside the
rulemaking process
is the form in here the the new form
that one that was adopted 120 for
reference is that in here as far as the
agents that we've seen it uh the copy of
that form is included in the packet yes
okay
any further comments by committee
so I back uh our our we can either we
can adopt the form uh understanding that
they need to deal with this form that
has to either come back to rule making
so they can adopt it is that correct
um at this time if you a uh adopt or
approve these particular rules in the
agency adopts them the effective date of
the form would change to the date of
now yes um the only reason that that was
made a substantive common is just so the
committee is aware that the agency did
make those changes outside the
rulemaking process great thank you any
further discussion for the agency or
questions for the agency
I'd entertain a motion to approve
it's been moved by representative Lynn
is there a second
it's been second by Senator Ward
any further discussion
seeing that emotion is to approve the
rule as presented all those in favor say
aye
opposed nay
eyes have it and the rules adopted thank
you
thank you happy holidays
next up is 22.99
um
Department of Health and Human Services
on a radiation safety requirements for
wire line service operators and
subsurface Tracer studies
sir um I'm actually going to take both
of these two together the next one is
also another rad roll so the agency is
requesting a postponement to the January
meeting
you still need to vote on when that
January meeting will take place but the
agency would like to request a
postponement and in order to do so you
will need to request a waiver of your
deadline
thank you so again remember for the new
members so agencies we have a certain
deadline in order to act on rules if we
need to if for some reason the agency in
this case needs an extension to be able
to work on it we have to waive that rule
so that they have time to work on it and
come back after the normal deadline so
I'd entertain a motion to wave
um wave rules and postpone items 22.99
and 100. so moved it's been moved by
representative Leon seconded by
representative Schmidt any further
discussion
all those in favor say aye aye opposed
name
the eyes have it it's been postponed and
the rules and the needed rules have been
waived for timeline
next up is the board of licensed
dietitians item number 22 131 yes sir
there's just one um comment to bring to
your attention and that's on page one of
the conditional approval request or page
two of the linked PDF depending on which
one you're looking at like I said um the
agency did file a conditional approval
request the comment although I've
indicated it's an unclear comment it
really should be a informational note to
the committee
the legislature has been working to
remove fee Authority from the boards and
to place that fee Authority with the
executive director of the oplc and here
I just wanted to make sure that the
committee was aware even though there is
a reference here to a renewal fee
by in another rule that the fees the fee
Authority doesn't line with the board it
is in fact with the executive director
this board does have fine Authority but
not fee Authority again and this is the
only comment and it is an informational
comment to the committee
before I go to the agency if in case
somebody has questions I'll let you know
that I served on SB 330's study
committee which is about oplc licensure
and process
um I do have a bill in to do cleanup we
have at one point we granted oplc
director the right to set fees
but we also have throughout the statute
statutes on all these different boards
places where the board also has
authority to set fees we have in two
different places I do have a LSR
submitted to clean up all that language
and go along with the most current law
we passed which was to move fee setting
Authority into oplc directly not the
board and the board is advisory in
nature and when it comes to fee setting
so there is legislative there is an LSR
presented based on Senate Bill 330 study
commission so that being said this will
be corrected in the law so Mr chairman I
think the members of the gel car should
be co-sponsors of that of your LSR so
it's clear that it's something that gel
car supports sure I'll make sure I had
that I haven't got language yet once I
get it because I'm sure it's going to be
very extensive considering the number of
places we talk about boards and fees and
oplc
so uh any further discussion or
questions
seeing not an antenna motion or approve
the rule 22 131 so moved
it's been moved to approve is there a
second second by representative Lynn uh
motion by representative Schmidt
any further discussion
seeing none all those in favor say aye
aye opposed name
eyes have it and uh the rule is adopted
thank you
all right the next one is
um border psychologist 22 149 and this
one is just an incorporation by
reference statement issue because
there's a new
um ethics principle document that there
that has come out in 2016.
um the agency decided that they they
want to go ahead and and go back to the
board and get that that document and
update that that date and so they're
asking for
um a postponement and gel car will have
to waive their deadline and then they
can come back around in January and
that'll be all fixed thank you so I'd
entertain a motion to postpone and wave
timeline requirements
so moved it's been moved by
representative Schmidt second by
representative Lynn to uh postpone and
wave timeline requirements on rule uh
22-149
any further discussion seeing none all
those in favor say aye aye opposed name
eyes have it and it's been postponed and
timelines waived
next stop is the mechanical licensor
board 22 171 on administrative
obligations okay this one is a little
confusing
um so there's nothing wrong with the
rule I have no comments on the rule the
issue was that back when the
um agency filed their notice to go in
the register
um there was a mix-up in the FIS so the
FIS that was published went to a
completely different Rule and said
completely different things and we
realized it and I'm not sure what
happened with the communication between
myself and the agency but um for some
reason we didn't get it fixed right at
the beginning and so it went out like
that and then we um it was it was
obvious that it was a mistake and that
you know just the wrong one had been
filed and so we asked for the correct
one
um we were immediately given the correct
one which is what you see here in the
meeting packet
um but it is a different FIS so there's
a question of whether there was full
notice
for when this went to the the public
originally so you have some options you
can either just approve it and move on
or
um you can kind of a little outside of
541 but a but you could request that the
agency have another hearing another
public hearing so that we would notice
them with the correct FIS they would
have another public hearing and then
they would come back for approval
um if this has happened
I've seen it happen once with an agency
that had a lot of people come to a
public hearing and some people didn't
feel like they had gotten enough time to
to say what they wanted to say at the
hearing
um and that was I believe it was Des or
fish and game
um and so they went back after the jail
car meeting had another hearing and then
came back to jailcar for approval after
they had done that
um
it's really up to the the committee tell
you more thank you Mr Vice chairman
um I've spoken extensively with Tina
Kelly about this
the initial fiscal impact statement that
was included was from a rule earlier
this year by the same board that
indicated there was an indeterminable
but minor uh
cost to the state but otherwise that was
it the actual the correct FIS indicates
no cost at all which is the case with
the rules
Tina also indicated that no one showed
at the public hearing no one supplied
written comment so it did not appear
that anyone was
misled or harmed by this as Christina
said you can approve the rule
you could
requests they have another public
hearing or you could request that they
put special notice in the rule making
register uh to indicate what happened
and include a copy of the correct FIS
represents Whitley
or senator
uh it seems to me the the latter might
make sense as a middle ground so putting
the correction in the rather than
holding a whole new
hearing to just put that change in the
register I think it makes a lot of sense
I agree with Senator Whitney entirely so
is that a motion senator
it's been moved to approve the rule and
to make a note in the register that the
incorrect FIS and posted corrected FIS
in the register is there a second to
that it's been seconded by uh uh
representative Lynn any further
discussion
seeing none all those in favor say aye
aye opposed name
eyes have it and it's been adopted
you guys are getting all the interesting
rules right so you're getting every type
final conditional interim so next up is
an emergency Rule and Mike can you just
let the uh again the new members explain
what emergency rule what what this means
to the uh board
certainly an emergency rule is allowed
for two reasons there's imminent Peril
to Public Health or safety or there's
going to be a substantial economic cost
to the state or citizens if the rule
because there is not time for regular
rule making to address the important
issue an example would be if there's an
outbreak of red tide then an agency
would do an emergency rule to a you know
stop clamming in other shellfish
um we sometimes find that there are
staff finds that there does not appear
to be
an emergency and we tell that to the
committee
an emergency rule is unusual in that
once they the agency writes it and
brings it to our office it is
immediately effective there is no public
hearing there is no other notice we do
publish it in the rule bank and register
um
in this instance I I would prefer that
the agency talk about the substance of
the emergency room
thank you so just some board members
understand we actually don't have a vote
on this right so the reality is it's
informational only they have the right
to make the emergency rule based on 541a
the only thing we could talk about is
potentially the fact whether we think
that the emergency truly exists or not
and and comment right if the committee
believes that there is no emergency or
that there may be an issue but it would
be better suited to regular rulemaking
then you can petition the agency
pursuant to 541a4 to repeal the rule oh
God
uh good morning Vice chair members of
the committee my name is Allison radmay
I am the administrator of the
administrative rules unit for the
Department of Health and Human Services
and with me I have my name is Beth
margeson and I'm the general counsel and
legislative liaison for the division for
children youth and Families
and we also have with us Steve Allen who
is the head of the policy unit whose
unit actually does our rulemaking
uh yes so um I'm actually probably going
to defer
um a lot to uh Eve because she has the
subject vendor expertise on this however
the um
the
rule is needed because the
um
we are
I guess if I could just see that
okay
um so the right now the New Hampshire
Foster families are not required to
receive the covid-19 vaccine in order to
be licensed and the reason that we are
doing this is at the division of Public
Health has not mandated covet vaccines
in the state of New Hampshire and also
it's it's necessary for us to retain our
foster families
um and uh the Department's immunization
requirements for children in foster care
have typically aligned with the federal
licensing standards for the United
States Department of Health and Human
Services following guidance from the uh
Centers for Disease Control so the CDC
recently updated its list of recommended
immunizations to include the covid-19
vaccine uh when we as a department
learned of this change we moved swiftly
to amend our administrative rules to
ensure that the covid-19 vaccine would
not be required for foster care
licensing and
um
so the uh in order for our
you know at this point our
administrative rules are not in
alignment so we need to do this carve
out to ensure that we are in in
alignment with the rest of the rules
um and so we are doing this on an
emergency basis
um at this time and then uh when the
rule is we intend to make the rule
permanent I guess in June when we open
up the rule for
um for further revisions
so um these changes will be put into
place permanently prior to the
expiration of the rule and internally
the department is working on that draft
to start getting that filed
and I would just ask Eve because I'm new
to this if there's anything that she
thinks needs to be added
I think you spoke to the situation very
well we are licensing standards follow
the federal requirements and they issued
new federal requirements in 2019 maybe
before covid
was here and those requirements required
immunizations to be present for
household members
that came out in February 2019 then we
had covet in 2020 the rule became
effective in 2020 but that was still
prior to the vaccine existence
since then the entities that are named
the federal standards for vaccine
requirements have amended one of the
three entities amended their vaccines to
include the vaccine to prevent covet and
we're trying to make sure that that
change that was not included in 2020
that has now become effective does not
impact our foster families so we're
trying to be proactive to make sure that
our rules that require vaccines to be in
a men are in alignment with those two
entities have this exceptions we're not
requiring families inadvertently to have
to have a covered vaccine and that's not
the intent
all right let me see if I can take all
of that and summarize it and something
that we can all understand so the short
version is the federal government could
change their rules to require covid I
know that we have a law because I I
wrote it that says that you can't
require the coveted vaccine for for uh
participation in certain things and so
what we're doing is creating this carve
out because even though the federal
standard says you have to have it we're
saying the state standard is that you
don't and that's what this rule does
correct and um so we again we took this
original rule
um in June of 2020 so I actually made
2020. so I think it was the first gel
car uh back since covet started and at
that time
um there were comments and questions on
what if there becomes or there is a
vaccine for covid uh how do we address
that and we did tell the committee at
that time that we would enter rulemaking
immediately uh to exempt the Foster
families from that requirement so we
tried to make thank you
discussion representative Whitley
Senator Whitley sorry
uh thank you Mr Mr Vice chair thanks for
taking my question so I'm just trying to
think through
have you spoken to whoever you need to
speak with at the federal government to
make sure we're not dinged on anything
I have reached out to representative
with the Children's Bureau to make sure
they're aware that we're making this
deviation from the model standards to
have an exception they were aware and
they said that we can hold on putting
our official for we plan amendment in
until the official Wiccan goes in but
they were agreeable to us making this
accept as long as we can validate the
reason behind it and that is the concern
about the impact on families and loss of
foster homes
thank you representative Luke
19 or is it a vaccine or is it required
um
the language says
the national model licensing standards
and the national model licensing
standards says that household members
will be in compliance with all
recommended vaccinations so it's that
Dance of the language where they're
requiring you to meet all
recommendations so it's
both terms unfortunately are part of the
sentence it just makes it strange
I'm sorry I understand what you're
saying I guess my only question then is
our
you seem to be okay with
having a state rule
that is in conflict with the Federal
rule as you've interpreted and I guess
my question is is that okay or you know
are we likely to have the feds come in
and say you're in violation of
and and therefore you lose some funding
or whatever
you plan with our federal Partners our
current title for
telephone model foster care licensing
standards that allows us to articulate
any deviations from the standards and as
long as we can give a valid reason as to
what reason we have to deviate that's
not putting any safety concern for
children or families then the feds will
review that and they'll sign off on it
and until they um if they when we put
the page in and they review it if they
decline it then becomes the compliance
issue that they've told us we're not in
compliance that we need to rectify it at
this point in time we've been
transparent with them that we're looking
at this deviation and they have not
expressed any concerns for us being out
of compliance
thank you
representative Lynn also says hey this
is similar to what we do at Medicaid
expansion right we have some exemptions
and differences in Medicaid expansion
that we file with the federal government
and say we're going to adopt Medicaid
expansion but we have some deviations so
it's not an uncommon practice for our
state to have a deviation from a federal
program and notify the feds to that we
do and then they'll decide whether or
not our deviation is too deviated and so
thank you very much because nothing to
vote on really thank you
Mike what else we have
as other business uh I've handed out a
draft tentative meeting schedule for
2023 we should vote on that uh by
Statute you would be meeting on Friday
January 20th anyways because the law
requires that the committee meet the
third priority of each month unless the
committee adjusts that
currently it's been the committee's
practice to meet on Fridays during the
session so January through June because
you're all otherwise busy on Thursdays
during the second half of the year when
you're out of session the meetings are
on Thursday so you don't have to come in
on a Friday in the middle of the summer
I assume Mike we've looked through these
dates to make sure we have no holidays
in any of these days so we'll have to
deal with later
um we did it several times with
different calendars I do believe that
this one's right but if it's not we can
fix it it's great so I'll move to
approve
so it's been moved by representative
Schmidt to approve the calendar as
written and presented is there a second
by representative Senator Ward sorry
I'll get used to that a little bit
further discussion yeah thank you Mr
Vice chair just a little note for my
participation I do have a conflict with
the children's oversight commission not
every single date is in Conflict but
that begins at 10 so there are times
that an alternate might be need to be
seated
uh an individual basis I could do an
hour here and then leave for the
oversight commission so I just wanted to
let you know about that
great that's why we have alternates
any further discussion uh representative
um thank you Mr Vice chairman
um my only question would be around the
December 21st I expected I'd probably be
traveling with family already if seating
an alternate it's acceptable that's
wonderful but I just wanted to raise
that now since I'm already planning to
miss that
thank you thank you
further discussion
it's been moved and seconded to approve
the gel car meeting dates all those in
favor say aye
aye opposed nay eyes have it in the
calendar is adopted
uh turn immoral yes Mr Vice chairman
um we would I'm sure the new members are
a little bit confused after this and
wonder what's going on we do plan to do
rulemaking training uh it should take
about an hour we can do that at the end
of the January meeting unless it's a
huge agenda and takes a long time and
the committee would rather defer that we
can also do individual training in our
office we can also send out materials
and perhaps a video to help the
committee members
thank you so let's let's plan on doing
at the end of the 20th let's also invite
all the alternates so they show up and
so they can get the training as well on
the 20th and so we'll have all a
full-time members all the regular
members and all the alternates present
at the meeting on the 20th we will do
that thank you
for the discussion
Senator Chandler thank you very much Mr
chair
um I'm just wondering uh
if this is the appropriate time but um
I'm wondering if it's the custom and
practice or a requirement for those not
in attendance at a prior meeting to
abstain from voting
um or approving the minutes
we've allowed it in the past okay so we
don't have a rule one way or another
they're in they can they're free to vote
they're free not to vote because the
potential is they could listen to the
audio in the video if they wanted to and
know what happened at the meeting and so
therefore feel comfortable voting so
okay thank you
uh just for informational for the
committee members on our website which
is under gen Court there's
administrative rules and under that
there are links to uh RSA 541a which is
the administrative procedures act there
is also a copy of the rulemaking manual
that's a rather long document it's a
requirement that agencies follow in
their Drafting and it also lays out the
process to go through a rulemaking
procedure it is compliance with it is
required by RSA 541a eight
there are we make a lot of editorial
comments you may have noticed on that we
don't bring those to the committee
unless we think there's going to be the
agency is going to be unwilling to make
the change and it would create a problem
there is also contained on the website
the committee's own rules
which are important and we're
in the midst of revising both the manual
and the committee's rules to bring them
up to date they when they're done we
will bring them forward to you for a
vote
great
any further discussions or my items if
not this meeting is adjourned
okay
he picked the right person today